olá isso mas giovanna sul do 4º ano eu
já vim explicar um pouco mais pra vocês
sobre o aquecimento global
primeiramente o que aquecimento global a
aquecimento do da lse elevação de
temperatura de calor nosso planeta em
excesso o que mais casos o aquecimento
global é o efeito estufa leve estufa a
contagem da seguinte forma a partir de
energia solar refletida pela atmosfera
terrestre ea outra parte é absorvida
pelos oceanos e mares isso promovem seu
aquecimento
o aquecimento global
caso algumas coisas ou consequência de
ruim é que pode acontecer no nosso
planeta e devemos nos preocupar
escolhi três que são bem potentes
primeiro é por causa do efeito estufa os
oceanos absorvem as águas e acaba
causando muitas seitas como essa aqui e
com ele com esse excesso de aquecimento
é acaba quebrando pedra bloco de gelo os
grandes e acaba de repente sbac os
impactos muito experiente mas planeta
e quando esse é se deve retirar o meio é
hoje mais bag é feito de gelo e usb gelo
e se o sbt vai ficar com vai cair água e
essa água vai cair no mar e escada
inundações e vai gastar muita água
com toda essa minha pesquisa resolvi
colaborar um pouco para isso não
acontecer mais
primeiro quando todos saídos dos seus
compartimentos tinha casa liga as duas
para não gastar energia e quando estão
escovando os dentes liga torneira para
não gastar água e uma banho a mesma
coisa
minutos é o máximo para ficar cheiroso e
não gastar água existe um símbolo e uma
imagem muito importante primeiro é esse
símbolo que você encontra em eletrônicos
de sua casa como a máquina de lavar a
parte treta significa você essa liga
quando for necessário e a parte amarela
significa que você é só liga quando for
necessária metade a metade
e essa imagem significa que eu é a minha
gatinha
se cada um de vocês ligar na gotinha vai
ficar o hotel e vai gastar muita água
obrigada pela atenção de todos está que
você também colaborem